-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
The Democratic
National Committee
held its annual holiday party
last night
outside of
the Hotel Washington due to
the spread of
the Omicron variant.
Meanwhile,
the Republican holiday party
just added more mistletoe.
President Biden attended
the DNC's annual holiday party
last night and gave a 10-minute
speech in just under an hour.
In his speech at
last night's DNC holiday party,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
praised President Biden
and said he was the "perfect
president for the times,"
because the times
are also very unpopular.
New York mayor-elect Eric Adams
announced yesterday
that he will appoint
Nassau County
Chief of Detectives
Keechant Sewell
as the city's first-ever
female police commissioner,
because isn't it time
a woman had
the worst job in New York?
Singer Grimes tweeted yesterday
that her ex-boyfriend,
Tesla C.E.O. Elon Musk,
cut his own hair
for his "Time" magazine
Person of the Year
magazine cover.
Well, it was either that or
he went to a Supercuts
and handed them
a picture of Beaker.
A New York
ethics board yesterday
gave disgraced former governor
Andrew Cuomo
30 days to pay back his
$5.1 million book deal.
And this might be the first time
he's reluctant
to kiss something goodbye.
According to the latest numbers,
deliveries by
UPS, FedEx, and USPS
are arriving at a
nearly perfect on-time speed,
so maybe tomorrow,
instead of taking the subway,
just mail yourself to work.
In a recent video on TikTok,
a Mississippi woman claimed that
she accidentally live-streamed
herself having sex
with her husband on Facebook.
Oh, weird.
I didn't even realize you could
still poke people on Facebook.
[ Laughter ]
I guess they also know
that punch line's
five years old.
And, finally, during
last night's game against
the New York Knicks,
Golden State Warriors star
Steph Curry broke the NBA record
for most 3-pointers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
And received a standing ovation
at Madison Square Garden,
which was tough for Knicks fans,
because they'd totally
forgotten how to do that.
And that was
a monologue, everybody.